okay it um it being 106. I'm going to go
ahead and open up today's division three
work session
the topics that we intend to cover today
we're going to continue with the office
of the commissioner of DHHS and within
that we're going to talk about the
office of Health Equity and the division
of program quality those were deferred
from Tuesday I believe we're also going
to listen to the Bureau of Information
Services and the facilities
Administration we're going to postpone
to another day
so I believe that's that's what we're up
for and and we'll we'll take it in
whatever order you care to pitch it
hi good afternoon
my name is Nathan white I'm the Chief
Financial Officer with the Department of
Health and Human Services as chairman
Edwards indicated earlier today we're
going to continue the office of the
commissioner with the Department of
Health and Human Services we're going to
start off with the office of Health
Equity
and from there we will be going to
dpqi and then Information Services later
this afternoon so with that I will hand
it over to Reuben and Anne
good afternoon thank you for having us
my name is Anne Landry I'm associate
commissioner
sorry
I think I've been silenced in my family
um no my name is Anne Landry I'm
associate commissioner for the
Department of Health and Human Services
and I would just like the honor of
introducing Reuben Hampton he can
introduce himself but he is our new
director of The Office of Health Equity
and he just started last week so we're
very excited to have him here for this
um the session and it's a great jump
into the work that we do
so I'll let you good afternoon I'm
Reuben Hampton very happy to be here
my director of The Office of Health
Equity
so you've been with us for a week uh
two and three quarters okay so you know
the important things you know how to
find the coffee pot you know where your
offices your where to park okay exactly
all right well good good welcome
well
so the mission of our office if you take
a look at the first slide is to first of
all ensure Equitable access to dhhs's
programs and services but overall to
improve outcomes for the marginalized
populations here in New Hampshire and
when you look at the key goals that fall
from that it's to ensure that access and
outcomes for DHHS programs but also
overall for these different groups from
various demographic backgrounds and part
of the way we're going to do that is
through good communication and taking a
look at these various services and at a
baseline level that's ensuring we're
complying with the various state and
federal mandates that we are beholden to
including the refugee Services Program
that falls under this group
can I can I uh I want to give I want to
give you an overview of how I think
about your your job and your role
um uh and it comes from
um a very military background uh we
we've seen in other presentations we had
a University of New Hampshire Professor
with us a few weeks ago who did a nice
thorough demographic lay down of New
Hampshire showing the demographics uh
relative it kind of in a heat map way
what you know what percentage lived
where
and um and so as I was listening to him
and seeing these Maps I started thinking
in a military mindset and to say uh okay
here here's a very specific set of area
codes in Nashua here's another specific
set of area codes up uh along the
Vermont border along the river here's
another one south of Berlin you know
they were very specific
clusters of of uh communities with I
would think marginalized populations and
so
um so as I'm looking at your
presentation I don't I don't I don't see
that kind of a geographic lay down of
where these sectors are
and I'm I'm just thinking it may help
over the long run you know not not
tomorrow not not even in this budget
cycle but in the long run I think if we
could uh connect the geographic spots
that were uh particular you know because
the people are living in a geographic
area generally right there's we're
seeing clusters uh that that that that
would help Focus us all on what we're
doing in a particular area and and
whether or not you know as we assess the
capabilities the clinical capabilities
in each of those areas
um whether or not they're adequate or
sufficient and and where they're not
then we have a corrective action plan to
go fix them and so it's it would be very
driven by
communities and specific geographies
tied to specific capabilities and an
assessment of each capability of whether
or not it's adequate that that's sort of
my military mindset and given that you
hear two and a half weeks I just thought
I'd share that with you and maybe get
your reaction to that
I appreciate the feedback and
perspective and certainly as you suggest
want to take a look at you know what
exists in the state from different areas
what the data says and what our
capabilities are in different areas
so have you seen uh the the kind of the
demographic mapping that I've described
because I I asked the professor for some
specific slides I don't mind emailing
them and I I don't know if that would be
new information to you or redundant with
something that you already have if
there's anything you'd like to share
we'd certainly be open to it
okay and at this point I'll just let you
talk I just thought I'd give you the the
a quick alignment on how I think we may
want to talk about these things in the
future thank you
So within the office we have two
different accounting groups one is for
Refugee Services one is for the rest of
the team which includes some of the
Communications office work Community
engagement
Etc
and you can see on the slide after that
we have the organizational chart which
speaks about some of those positions
following that we also have some of the
key accomplishments of the office from
the past State fiscal year you'll see
that we've done a lot from the refugee
Services standpoint particularly in the
area of employment to get a lot of the
folks both employed and with a good
hourly wage we've also seen a lot in the
hearing speech and vision area of doing
both putting together a lot of kits and
a lot of trainings and Communications
access overall a lot of effort that's
been put into improve standards and get
folks trained
and from a challenges standpoint some of
these things are honestly unique to
this office but from a housing
standpoint not necessarily unique to New
Hampshire overall but wanting to find
housing for those in need and
transportation as well and from
Communications X at standpoint we
continue to push to get devices and
services and and training for folks to
be able to use those so clients from all
backgrounds can continue to access these
services
thank you Mr chairman just to put in
perspective
um of I know that we've seen an increase
in refugees coming to the state is there
any way you can share with me where we
were maybe two years ago at this time in
the budget process versus now in terms
of numbers of peoples that have been
welcomed into our state
okay
um we we have the arrival information
from the last few years and we can
certainly share more widely on that it's
on our website but we don't have a
handout
um we have the general numbers that are
coming up over the last few years but I
just wanted to um acknowledge one piece
of that so in the last year and a half
as we know there have been through the
um
the conflicts in Afghanistan and the
Ukraine we've seen an inbox of refugees
um
seeking Asylum from those two countries
but it's actually that means our our
kind of standard program of refugee
resettlement from the federal government
has actually reduced those numbers so we
haven't actually seen an increase in
those arriving to New Hampshire just the
composition has been changed based on
the needs of the ukrainians and the
Afghan Sands of the Afghans I'm sorry
thank you very much
and and and just to just to follow up on
that from a budgetary standpoint what
what you'll see in account 7209
in classline 102 that this is 100
federal federal funds you will you will
see that increase within um within class
102 there uh and and those are the those
are the awards that we're projecting
from the federal government uh to
address that issue
representative walner
and those awards are given because our
numbers are going up
or because the needs of the refugees are
that are coming are greater yes thank
you for that question representative
it's it's more about the overall needs
of those who have arrived from
Afghanistan and the Ukraine
um and the federal government has has
been generous I think throughout with
all the states and then in the amount of
funding but not because there's been an
increase I I will just acknowledge
there's an increase between Federal
fiscal year 21 and federal fiscal so the
refugee program is on a federal fiscal
year not a state fiscal year but there
was an increase that looks more drastic
but that was because of a result of kova
during the acute phase of the pandemic
there were there was a reduction just
generally in the number of folks that
were coming to the U.S
um and then those numbers started to
increase back to a normal rate across
the country so but as a whole the
increase in the numbers from Ukraine and
Afghanistan didn't increase our overall
numbers very much
thank you very much for your for being
here appreciate it yeah is there any uh
the 900 000 interagency transfer from
7209 that's going to 7208 does that
correspond to the contract for program
services and can you comment a little
further on what those are sure so in
account 7209 class 85
those are again 100 federal dollars
um those are those are transferred to
the um the Bureau of family assistance
and and that is used for
um cash assistance and that so so so
basically
um they would follow the same process
that whether they're a refugee or a New
Hampshire citizen they would apply for
benefits through that and then the
applicable criteria would be applied to
determine whether they're eligible or
not
are okay and it's just a coincidence
that it's the same amount as uh hit the
mic speaker yeah the same as a category
um same amount as by coincidence and
7208 for contract for program services
at the top of page 1074.
yes yes that that is a coincidence
um that particular class line is
primarily used to pay for the language
Bank contract which is uh roughly 74
General funds and 26 Federal
I don't see any other questions you can
so
if we take a look at the next slide just
to give an idea of
how how many folks we've been serving
you can see from Refugee program
standpoint we continue to serve a good
amount of people so on on the left side
of the chart you'll see the year and
this is on a state fiscal year
standpoint so we've converted that to
the refugee program
and
serve the same amount as last year
roughly so 1500 note for the refugee
program this is an estimation because we
could give a five-year roll total
because we provide services up to five
years for refugees however the team has
estimated based on who's rolled in and
who's rolled off what the actual number
of people they've served on in any given
year rather than give you a five-year
figure which might not actually be
accurate so this is the most accurate we
can get for clients served
and for communication assistant counters
you'll see on the right this is anyone
who's requested assistance from a
linguistic standpoint from a speech
Vision uh hearing standpoint or also or
who required any type of translation
services
may just um
I was mentioning with the state Refugee
program those numbers are not the
arrival numbers per year that's the
total population served so you know we
might have anywhere from less than 100
to
um 400 folks arrive in a given year
usually around a little bit less on that
so but as Ruben said they're they're
eligible for services up to five years
our team through our contracts works
it's really hard to ensure that they
have all the social supports medical job
training in order to be acclimated and
to be employed and then be
self-sufficient which is the whole goal
of refugee resettlement program often
that a lot of that happens in the first
six months for some folks it's up to a
five-year program and with Elders as
well and then on the second side I just
I wanted to highlight I'm sorry with the
communication access I'm going to ask
you to get the microphone I'm sorry so
this helps me because I'm actually deaf
it's my Ada reasonable accommodation to
ask you to do that no I apologize my
voice does not project well so on the
second half with the communication
access assisted counter encounters
you'll notice there's quite a bit of
increase in 2021 in that
um
State fiscal year and that is the result
of during the pandemic we served with um
the American sign language translators
through all the governor's press
conferences as well as offered
interpreters Services as requested or
needed at testing sites or vaccination
sites or anything related so that's why
there's such an increase in that year
given the Statewide efforts and the in
the governor's press conferences so I
just wanted to explain that because it's
quite noticeable so I recall from last
budget that you actually do quite a
number of different languages there's
that that this is says communication
access but that's primarily translation
right and and there's 20 or so languages
that you actively support
I I would have to get back to you with
the exact number but there are a good
amount of languages that we do provide
translation for we also provide ASL
support as well and other accommodations
for folks who do need help whether
that's from a vision standpoint hearing
standpoint
as well so so deaf guys like me
um we have with our contracts through
this language Bank we're able to access
either through a live interpreter or
kind of a video interpreted service for
for any language that is needed
um that's kind of the benefit of the
contract and and we also so we serve we
through the communication Access program
we ensure that those seeking our
services have have access to any whether
it's deaf and hard of hearing whether it
is a um
any language and then we also ensure
that our contracts through our vendors
that while we don't provide the services
through that contracted work that we're
ensuring that their compliant should
they be serving folks that have that are
deaf or hard of hearing or have other
interpretation needs
so I I that that completes your what you
anticipated right can can you just
answer a general question then as
um and and maybe Ms Landry you can you
can answer this as well so in the next
two years what do you see your biggest
challenge in this area
I'm still working on understanding the
different roles the needs of the
community right
it will be you know somewhat what you
suggested which is to understand you
know what are the you know targeted
needs right where should we be
allocating our time and our resources in
terms of helping and providing
assistance right and going from there
all right do you want to add to that Mr
Landry
I would just add that
um to complement what Reuben said is you
know we this office has been without a
director for two years and so part of my
role in overseeing the office of Health
Equity kind of as associate commissioner
and interim director was to bring on an
experienced director who can go out into
the communities to do exactly what
you're asking so to work internally with
our all of our programmatic areas to see
where there may be opportunities as well
as go out into the community across the
state right rural areas urban areas
anywhere where we feel that there's to
better understand the needs across the
Spectrum and so then Ruben's going to
help through his leadership bringing
that back and and hope in two years
you'll know from us whether there's any
expansion of programs or what have you
uh did you have a question
representative
thank you Mr chair could you just uh
tell me what so there's a slight
increase in the general funds of the
7208 program I'm just curious where that
is in the in the accounts
so
[Music]
I am 99 no don't say 99. we'll say uh
86.5 certain that's given it to Friday
um that that the language Bank contract
there
I I think that's it but but I have to go
back and look at the history so so let
me follow up with you that way I'm not
speculating
that's great but which one you're
guessing what number
I
I believe it's the language bank but but
I I because that's a 74
uh generally funded contract and and 26
Federal so instead of the higher match
that we typically see within this
account no that's great but I'm looking
at I don't see language Bank in the list
of in the budget
so it actually shows up in 70 in class
102. that that's where the contract is
for for the language Bank
so on page uh 1074 yeah yeah yeah that
we we can't list the actual names of the
contracts within the client within the
contract line but a way down below okay
God thank you yep of course
all right
oh you both represent Walton go ahead
so I wondered if for this office did you
have any uh prioritized needs in your
request of a governor for this office no
we did not okay thank you
yeah so if I looked in a list of
contracts I'd probably find the language
Bank under there somewhere
um or 700 plus contracts that
it would be the the vendor name would be
a centria
and and the legal name for clarification
um within that document that that you
received it's it's the Secretary of
State registered name that will show up
I'm fairly certain it's a century is
sometimes there's there's doing business
names or DBA names but those won't show
up there
thank you
I'm not seeing any other questions thank
you
so much
thank you are you going to live in
Manchester where are you going to live
I'm currently living in Concord oh okay
all right there's a housing shortage I
don't know if you know that yet I'm
aware
all right
um so so next up we have the division of
program quality integrity
joined by
hi my name is Tasha Blanchard and I'm
the administrator for the Bureau of
program integrity under Meredith
director of the Bureau of program
quality wasn't able to join us this
afternoon so if they're real specific
questions around that we may have to
take it back but otherwise Tasha and I
will answer anything we can for you so
we're starting on um
on the division of program quality and
integrity mission statement is the first
slide for us
um I don't I don't know if I have a page
number here oh page nine of the slide
deck
and the division of program quality and
integrity as you can see supports the
mission of the department by providing
data informed program development
quality performance Improvement and
ensuring accountability and operations
and financial integrity
and if you flip the page you'll see some
of our major goals
here one is to Design Systems of
provider and contractor management
and we do that in a few different ways
we we assess provider risk and if
there's Financial Risk we would work on
provider monitoring for that risk for
appropriate expenditure funds and we
also develop and Implement systems of of
financial provider oversight
we also um are establishing a consistent
department-wide quality definition and
framework everyone in the department all
of the program areas in the department
are working on providing quality
services but they can be using different
definitions and different methodologies
so we're trying to standardize and we
provide consistent framework for that
we do we work on data collection and
transparency to improve health outcomes
this is in the Medicaid sphere the
behavioral health sphere the drug and
alcohol sphere we have a comprehensive
systems of monitoring performance
indicators and then evaluating results
relative to the established goals we
work with stakeholders and we have
access to Medicaid data primarily to
work do analytics in the Medicaid
quality information system there are 200
metrics in that system related to the
Medicaid population that we are
monitoring for Quality all the time
uh we also have reportable performance
metrics that are established in
contracts enabling evaluation so that
program areas who are getting Services
delivered through contracts can assess
whether or not the contracts are meeting
their needs meeting the goals of their
of their programs and then they can
adjust those contracts or adjust their
strategy if they need to based on the
performance metrics that they're using
uh we also
um monitor compliance with federal and
state laws regulations and guidance so
we collaborate with programs and federal
Partners when there's a federal audit we
sort of act as a liaison between the
program areas and the Auditors to make
sure that the Auditors are getting every
piece of information that they've
requested all of their requests are
responded to when there are findings we
make sure that the program areas have
followed up with the findings and if
there are questioned costs we would make
sure the question costs get paid if if
we agree that it's appropriate to do so
um so yeah track and remediate audit
findings develop tools for internal
controls to mitigate non-compliance
risks
um and then we would also yeah conduct
data collection and validation analytics
and evaluation of um Health Services
Delivery Systems and and that's
federally required for the Medicaid
Program
so we ensure compliance in that area as
well
on slide 11 that is a high level org
chart of the whole division
so uh myself director we have an
administrative assistant and then we
have our three areas we have the Bureau
of program Integrity which I'll go into
first and then the Bureau of program
quality and we also have an office of
internal audit
so Bureau of oh key accomplishments I'm
sorry
key accomplishments
um these are kind of across the whole
division so in program quality first we
had the implementation of Quality
Reporting System for the adult Medicaid
dental benefit
adult Medicaid dental benefit is
anticipated to be um uh available for
our beneficiaries by April 1 and to do
that work we had to select all of the
performance metrics that we're going to
use to make sure that the benefit is
live and providing quality services and
that there's an adequate network of
dentists available to people and for
that we developed 78 different measures
tables plans and narrative reports that
we will be receiving from our Dental
managed care plan
um integration of Health analytics into
the Medicaid Eligibility unwind uh which
is the the discontinuation of coverage
based on the end of the public health
emergency we've developed a Medicaid
monthly Medicaid director's remedy
report on Managed Care Organization
performance standard violations so when
they are
uh in in when our Managed Care
organizations are in any way not meeting
our standards we have a single report
that captures all of that information at
once and can be presented to the
Medicaid director all at once it's it's
a very comprehensive report
um and then recently within the last
year and I think we've discussed this
with the division a little bit already
we created the contracts quality
management unit which is a unit intended
to look at
um the contract non-medicade the other
contracts the other 400 contracts that
we have with vendors in the community so
that we can establish some performance
metrics to make sure those vendors are
meeting our service requirements and
expectations and getting the department
closer to its ultimate goals
on program Integrity some of our key
accomplishments we we had been short
staffed in our our special
investigations unit which
um
which recovers money from beneficiaries
when it was incorrectly issued or issued
from fraud so from that we had uh having
been short staffed we had a backlog both
of claims and fraud investigations and
over the last year or so Tasha with her
staff have managed to eliminate the
claims backlog and they brought the
fraud investigation backlog down from
over a hundred to just over 300. so that
was
sorry thank you they brought it from 800
down to 300 which is the direction we
wanted it to go
uh We've also separated our provider
enrollment functions we're responsible
for Medicaid provider enrollment
um and we're responsible for
investigation of providers for fraud
waste and abuse those had been combined
uh which was making it very difficult
for the administrator to focus on either
adequately so we split those out so we
can have a real emphasis on both areas
we revamped our financial Compliance
Unit so that we can do better Federal
audit oversight and subrecipient
monitoring and we strengthened uh MCO
oversight of fraud waste and abuse and
third-party liability through
standardized meetings and consistent
reports that we're getting from our
Managed Care organizations
and I realize I'm talking a little bit
fast and possibly using um
language that that is unfamiliar to the
division so I'm going to pause for a
minute and see if folks have questions
so far
I think there's a question
favorite question
um regarding the monthly Medicaid
directors remedy report is that publicly
available
I don't believe it is I think that's
something we keep internal between us
and the Medicaid director the the
metrics however the quality metrics are
public on our mqis system so it's the
Medicaid quality information system and
that's a public website great thank you
and then in the area of internal oh is
it sorry
okay
uh in the area of internal audit we
established a formal mechanism to ensure
compliance with executive order
201403 which requires updates on the
progress of corrective actions for LBA
Audits and we also had developed and
socialized a toolkit across the entire
department for standardized policies and
Crea and procedures so anybody and work
instructions so anyone across the
department who doesn't have a good
robust process for creating their own
policies and procedures can use this
toolkit and guidelines and templates to
do that
challenges we have these are the same
challenges we had in the last biennium
it's really Workforce capacity in order
to support some of the high-level data
analytic work that we do
um and identify the key trends and the
key opportunities that we want to use to
improve health outcomes
and information systems and software and
funding for kind of robust modern
systems that allow us to do the work
is that an is system specifically for
you or just generally available across
the department so that you have
something to access there
there are us that
would use if we had access to them
um there are also vendors that we could
use who have their own systems that if
we contracted with those vendors would
be able to to utilize their systems for
example I'll say for third party
liability is an example that's not
something we can house robustly in-house
but there are vendors on the market that
have that capability
representative thank you I noticed your
budget you had an increase in technology
spending as a actual software it sounded
like is this this the area that's aimed
at that might be your
um I don't know if that's your qio yeah
I think that's probably what that is
the qio
and just to clarify and you you're
you're speaking to account 7935
um the technology software class 38
oh it says it's Equifax
Equifax is that the Equifax uh
yeah that might be our Equifax contract
that we have to use to ID to identify
people's addresses for our special
investigations unit and also for
um
uh to identify income for our quality
assurance unit yep identify employment
um
that's the qio yeah okay and then there
is another one which is software
um for qio which is the what's qio stand
for
quality improvement organization this is
a function where we have to review the
name is a little confusing it's really a
function where we have to review all of
the inpatient stays inpatient hospital
stays and there's a single standardized
software that you can use to kind of
help you understand does this meet all
the criteria for an inpatient stay or
does it not I mean ultimately it comes
down to judgment uh and so we have staff
who are helping make that judgment but
there is a standardized software you use
to make that determination so it's like
it's licenses For That that helps
um so I didn't quite hear a yes with the
funding that you have are requesting in
that line is is that the money that you
need to address this weakness that
you've identified thank you no it's not
it's continuation of current operations
all right
on page 14 slide 14
outline some detail of the work of the
Bureau of program integrity
and is outlined here in the bullets the
bureau includes our special
investigations unit
which does the uh
referrals for fraud for beneficiaries
our Medicaid Program Integrity unit
which does investigations for fraud
waste and abuse
for Medicaid providers not beneficiaries
but providers
our Medicaid provider enrollment unit
that enrolls Medicaid providers
and our Medicaid third party liability
unit that does cost avoidance so that
Medicaid is the pair of Last Resort and
cost recoveries
and the Medicaid Program Integrity unit
and third party liability unit also in
addition to doing that work on behalf of
the FIFA service populations they also
do the oversight of the mco's work that
they're doing in those respects for the
Managed Care population so the con it's
kind of contract management of our mcos
that work is equal to or greater than
probably the work we do for fee for
service
we also have the quality assurance unit
they do federally required audits of
snap eligibility determinations
supplemental nutritional Access program
um
sometimes called food stamps but the
snap program eligibility determinations
that the department does we're federally
required to take a sub-sample of those
and make sure that they were done
correctly and the right allotment was
given out
and the financial Compliance Unit does
um
reviews and audits of nursing home cost
reports they do sub-recipient monitoring
for vendors that receive federal funds
they do Medicaid to schools audits
am I missing anything
they do all the federal audits oh and
they do all of the liaising for federal
audits so our single audit which is our
our largest Federal audit they do the
liaising between the program areas and
the Auditors but they would do that for
any specific Federal audit that we get
as well
are are and then internal audit of
course um as I as is exactly how it's
described internal audit would do an
audit of the department at Management's
discretion
so any questions on the Bureau of
program integrity
representative stream so it looks like
you'll recover about two million dollars
a year where does that money go uh in
the budget
that just stay in your apartment or
total total so uh the portion that is
returned that is federal funds goes back
to the federal government and these are
mostly Medicaid monies or or uh snap
money snaps 100 Federal and then
Medicaid is a mix of federal in general
those would go back be returned to the
federal government and the portion that
is General funds goes into revenues for
the general fund so it does not stay in
the department
unrestricted revenues
thank you and follow-up um and and
that's where the 30 plus employees
reside from your earlier chart
um
this Bureau actually has 71. okay well
all of those are in here okay thank you
yeah
that's right
any other questions go ahead
I guess first of all just to clarify we
have my qai
operations no
I'm not in the wrong place on the budget
briefing book or qai is probably the
6637 it's oh I I actually oh that's it
oh and then that says oai
yes 79.35 is the accounting unit and I I
apologize the names have changed so they
don't always align but I think you're
looking are you looking at the budget
this book
budget narrative I'm not trying to
budget but quality the yeah sorry the
budget briefing book quality assurance
and Improvement
you haven't gotten there yet
I'm just trying to you you do talk fast
back and forth between documents while
you're done it's good it's all good in
the
yeah I don't know if you're in the
budget or our budget in the budget
budgeting book in the budget budget okay
so the one we are describing right now
is on page 1076 of the budget I'll go
back yep and it's uh accounting unit
79.35 you got it okay yeah that's also
if you the cheat sheet is at the bottom
of these
um slides
got it got it okay
uh so on slide 15 is a a chart that just
shows what's happening with a couple of
our recoveries uh as you can see our
fraud wasted abuse recoveries have been
increasing our TPL recoveries have been
declining that's okay because what's
happening is that the mcos a lot of the
TPL work has been shifted to the mcos so
they do that recovery for fraud waste
and abuse where it's a fraud case the
mcos cannot keep the recovery the state
keeps the recovery those get referred
over to the doj and and pursued by the
doj and so the recoveries are kept by
the state
and if you go to slide 16 the Bureau of
program quality
there are five units within the bureau
including our data analytics and
Reporting
and data analytics and Reporting is
focused really on Medicaid data
analytics and Reporting so they uh
manage all of our mmis Medicaid
management information systems data and
they use that for the purposes of of all
kinds of things understanding
demographics understanding rates
um
and within that unit is the a subunit
which manages the mqis the Medicaid
quality information system website that
I referenced earlier
there's also the Medicaid quality
program which is federally mandated for
us to have a Managed Care Quality
strategy so that strategy is written and
managed within that unit and that's
where we sort of set priorities for the
Medicaid Program and then we hold our
Managed Care
organizations
accountable for achieving some of that
quality
the substance misuse planning and
evaluation unit is a unit of one
individual who is a subject matter
expert in substance misuse and really
understands nationally uh what happens
both within Clinical Services but also
um
an outcome
measures and the intended outcomes of
substance misuse services and so he
works very closely both with our
Medicaid quality program to help set
some of those metrics and he also works
with our Bureau of drug and alcohol
Services directly to help manage their
vendors who are non-medicaid
our health services assessment unit does
uh
intensive Clinical Services audits of a
number of our providers they monitor the
community mental health centers in
compliance with the Community Mental
Health agreement they monitor CFI
providers and they work with other
program areas to develop similar sort of
Deep dive Clinical Services reviews so
that they can go into providers and make
sure they're providing services that
meet our standards and are in compliance
with our administrative rules
and then our contracts quality
management unit is the new one that that
I described earlier that is working with
all the program areas across the
department in order to set up
performance metrics they can use to
manage their contracts
and this oh
share
I think she caught up with me
um so this this is what I was asking the
question and it is qai
right
q a operation yes in the yes the
accounting unit title yes is quality
assurance and Improvement operation so
page 1091 of your budget of the budget
yes
yes it looks like you're adding a person
or maybe more I'm just
curious as whether or not you what the
likelihood is that you can hire that one
or more people sure so so it's actually
being transferred from accounting units
7935. you'll you'll see a one FTE
reduction in that accounting unit
and on the next slide or the next couple
slides I think I just have a couple
examples uh of some of the work
being done in the Bureau of program
quality
so on slide 17 you will see some of the
priority performance measures that the
department had selected that the
Medicaid services had selected working
with our chief medical officer to
prioritize and really try to highlight
in our most recent round of Managed Care
contracts so there are areas around
um
perinatal care around uh adult care
around and a few related to child care
so so Children's Health including
immunizations weight assessment and
counseling
um and there's another one first line
use of first line psychosocial care for
children and adolescents on
antipsychotics
so because it's the top one let me ask
on the chlamydia screening it the goal
is
61.7 percent is is that's
61.7 percent of all women on receiving a
Medicaid
benefit is that what that 61 percent of
what is
I think it is the national Medicaid
Managed Care metric
so if you look at the next page uh slide
timeliness of prenatal care
you'll see the New Hampshire Medicaid
Trend and this is this is exactly the
kind of information you'll see on the
mqis the Medicaid quality information
system website you'll see charts just
like this you can click into each of
these uh measures and be able to see a
chart just like this one
and in this case the definition of
timeliness of prenatal care you'll see
at the bottom the measure definition the
percentage of deliveries that received a
prenatal care visit as a member of the
organization in the first trimester or
within 42 days of enrollment in the
Managed Care Organization and the
comparator here for 2021 it says it's a
82.1 percent and then the national
Medicaid Managed Care 75th percentile
for 2021 was 89.3 so if we go back to
the prior page timeliness of prenatal
care
0.8
of course those don't quite match so I
am going to double check that for you
okay I I was just I'm sort of still
curious on the on the previous page said
that we've accomplished 48 of the
screenings with a target of 61.7 percent
and I'm just curious what the population
is that we're considering are we
considering every woman on receiving a
Medicaid benefit is that what that 61 of
those are only in the Managed Care
population okay this reflection so all
that data would come through the Managed
Care organizations it's in our encounter
data for these women and these are
nationally reported hedis metrics so
so if they if the woman gets true uh
um services from a family planning
clinic or a federally qualified Health
Clinic is that is that data portable in
a way in which we have visibility of
who's getting what screening it wouldn't
matter which provider provided the
screening it is so the data itself is
portable it dumps into a single database
somewhere
yeah we would have access to which of
the women received that service
regardless of what provider they
received it at
okay
so that's not part of the I.T problem
that you're trying to solve no no okay
are you are you close to wrapped up yes
okay so there was a slide you and I
talked about and I'm just curious if you
don't think the slide's necessary or or
you're still working on it it was the
kind of the the 10-year snapshot I'm
back to the 10-year plan and you're
either in year two or three but you're
you're not near your tenure do you have
a sort of a 10-year view of where we're
going we didn't present
sure but this would get us through years
three and four of a 10-year plan
if if you're currently in year two and
you're trying to get out to year 10 then
this two-year budget would cover years
three and four
and and just to clarify you you're
partly referring to what uh the
commissioner was talking about when she
was talking about her road map and that
a road map was just for the initial kind
of 12-month period
no this is an ongoing conversation that
must tell us and I have had for a year
and a half I think I think it's it's
Department wide I I think what you're
curious about though is Department wide
right metrics that would be used to
Across the department in all program
areas and and that would help Future
Finance committees right to know
what are the metrics associated with
what kind of resourcing we should invest
based on the workload that would be one
set of metrics the other would be are
there quality metrics in these internal
programs so that we know whether or not
we're getting our money's worth
So within the the budget briefing books
um that have been provided we did add
and and this is a new feature we we did
add into into many of those sections
um performance metrics now there as as
you know and as as Meredith and you have
discussed
um you know there there's no today
there's no centralized result based
accountability type of metric system or
or unified logic model but there are
different indicators across every
Division and every
um program area that that can be used as
as metrics but but there there's also in
the agency budget request there's the
Form B which has which has some of those
metrics and and that form is issued by
the Department administrative Services
it's it's required
um under rsa9 as part of the part of the
annual budget process
um but but what we've tried to do at
least initially for this cycle is
include within those briefing books
um those performance metrics that can at
least begin to lay the foundation for
for specifically what you're talking
about or we have the better perfect
logic model where you can see here's my
dollars here's my outcome here's the
output what's this costing what's the
ratio what's the funding mix associated
with all of that
so in the
budget briefing book for Bureau of
program Integrity on page 10. you'll see
an example this is what you would see in
the form B for every accounting unit as
well
actually I shouldn't say this by
accounting unit level it might be by
activity level so at a slightly higher
level in The Form B there would be this
exactly this type of form with these
sort of outcome intended output intended
outcome baselines and goals
and that will be in the entire budget
briefing book
Mr chair
go ahead so just to follow up on that
great this is what we've been looking at
but what we haven't seen is the results
so I guess in that 10-year plan we're
talking about it that's where I was
hoping it was less than that but
whatever it is when will we start seeing
that side of the equation
just ballpark Madison from day and month
yep and and I know I totally understand
the question
when the Formby was originally rolled
out some of us asked the same question
oh this is very interesting you can
always see where people are aiming and
you never exactly see where they've come
from so completely understand it I don't
know that we have a mechanism to do that
at this point
yeah I I mean I've I've seen I I
formally worked in another state and
they they had a smart program for every
area across the department and it
tracked it had those performance metrics
across every division every Bureau
within that state and you you had year
one where you established your Baseline
you had year two three four and whatnot
and then you had your target metrics
going forward
um I guess that's one challenge with the
existing budget system budget process
that we do have where we don't
necessarily have that history
um again this is sort of my first
go-around in this role and that and and
I think by establishing these within
this budget briefing book I mean it's
it's my long-term intent to continue to
try to build off of that so that we have
that history and that record in in one
single location
so just uh I've heard our chairman speak
about this 10 unit plan
are you guys is this part of what you
could what you guys have been talking
about so that within this tenure plan
we'd expect to see that because that's
sort of when I hear him when I hear him
say that what I hear is that's what
we're going to get so I'm just wondering
if we're all on the same page or if I'm
out in you know left field or something
I think one of the one of the challenges
currently is
um our our commissioner is is in an
interim role for the next year um she
chose not to to start a four or five
year type strategic plan but instead the
the the the one-year plan to get things
moving
um to address many of the key priorities
that she's identified so I think within
you know within the coming year I mean
that that will kind of be the price one
of the key drivers behind many many of
the sort of resource devotions that um
or allocations you know that that we
will be moving towards but but I think
one of the complexities is that it you
know when when Trisha Tilley comes in
next week for Public Health
she has many federal grants she has many
performance indicators she is a team of
folks that focus on data to get to the
point to have the unified system I think
that's where you know it would be
beneficial for for us to go I I think
it's also just important to recognize
the tremendous amount of resources and
and I.T systems and data systems and
Reporting metrics and analysts that that
would be required to get us there
um so I I think we'd probably have to go
back and have a longer conversation with
a commissioner
um about about how this could be be
woven into the
um you know the the 12-month road map
that that is in the process of being
implemented
follow-up
that's great
um and I think it would be good though
if
if we could flesh out what what it you
know what kind of time frame this is on
um you know because then certainly I
think within 10 years you ought to be
able to do this uh if and if not we
should know that because it is really
hard to sit through these briefings and
uh
year after year and many many years
after sometimes decades after decades
and
not be able to actually see it how
effective are these programs is it
really should we be spending this money
here or should we be spending it over
there uh kind of a thing
um so really nice to know if you guys
are and I get it I understand the
commissioners
you know only thinking a year ahead but
I'm just wondering if there's not that
the plan is in place but that we're
thinking about having such a plan
I think that's sort of what the chairman
I don't want to speak for the chairman
but you did it better than I did so
speak for me anytime
all right so we'll we'll keep talking
about it I I understand that the
commissioner's focus on the next year I
got it all right thank you thank you any
other questions
representative hole do you have any
questions you want to share any jokes
with us or
yeah
all right all right thank you
Information Services this is great two
o'clock very good thank you
good afternoon my name is David Wieters
Information Services director for DHHS
Mr chair members of the committee Dennis
Goulet the commissioner for the
Department of Information Technology
so I'll try to be as brief as possible
to get us out on time but also give you
as much information as you have and
answer your questions as the best I can
so thank you for having me
the information Services Bureau is
really here to collaborate and identify
opportunities
within our organization to really
integrate technology with a focus on
empowering those employees and the
individuals that we serve to in a secure
and data-driven environment to deliver
our services so that you'll find that on
slide I think that was slide 19. it's
where we're starting and then moving on
to the next slide it's really some of
our our goals and what we're trying to
do so with technology and in partnership
with the information technology
department we're looking to provide
seamless and efficient individual care
services at the point of care without
unnecessary duplication or delay
and that sort of finds itself in lots of
our different systems across the
services and programs that we deliver
but the key highlight that we're working
on right now and we'll be continuing
into the next biennium is care
coordination via Statewide networks for
service referrals care plans and event
notifications for Missions discharge and
transfers
so there's some contracts in play right
now that will be moving forward we
already have an event notification
system that we're rolling out and
expanding the network and then we're
moving towards a closed-loop referral
system and some of you may have been
part of legislation in the last session
associated with that and our goal is to
make sure it is maintains the privacy
and the security of the information that
we're containing with informed consent
with each individual as they use those
systems so we really are trying to
listen to our individuals in our state
as well as the legislature to empower
and build these integrative Solutions as
we go forward
representative irf for a question thank
you Mr chairman Madam chair
so regarding that since you brought it
up so forthrightly in addition to
privacy
the system as it was being discussed at
one point was very Broad in terms of
extending Beyond Medicaid
People to non-medicate People
and I'm wondering that's still the case
and if so are those folks aware are they
able to choose to opt in and opt out
when they want to if they have opted in
if you follow where I'm going with this
certainly um thank you very much for the
question representative erf the new
solution is certainly going to be broad
for different services not just Medicaid
services and health care services but
also Social Services as as they operate
but the individuals will be able to opt
in to that through a consent process to
in to know who who they're sharing their
information with and for why and then of
course have the option to remove that
consent if they so choose as they go
through the the process so if someone
was up at a housing supports
organization and was getting a referral
for mental health services that you
would be presented with that type of
consent document saying we're sharing
your information with XYZ Mental Health
Center
to provide these Services is this
something that you would like and if
they so choose to say yes and sign they
would be provided that referral if they
say no they could then opt into a
different solution of saying but you can
call them for me or you can email them
for me or you can provide me the
information so there'll be lots of
different Alternatives so we have really
tried to address that accessibility as
well as the privacy and security
component follow-up follow up thank you
very much for that Clarity that's really
great to hear
thank you
so on on some of the are we good
absolutely please continue Mr readers
thank you so the other goal is to
provide better services for individuals
and drive improved outcomes through
enhanced decision making and
productivity and this really flows into
many different components of Information
Services one is data portal so you'll
probably hear about data in many
different presentations including
program quality and integrity but we're
looking to provide secure and price and
privacy oriented internal and external
Solutions through a managed data
governance process
with the goals of being able to
streamline and be able to track and do
some of these Services over time it does
take a lot of work to build the
foundations and because of different
privacy laws and security laws or
surrounding our data sometimes we're not
able to do that and that's for our
individuals and our and the services
that we offer not always can we combine
that information so that also puts some
some delays in working that through but
we're gold at building those data
portals to really utilize that
information to provide better data
driven data-driven decision making
and then moving into some of the
accessibility components we're looking
for mobile mobile and self-service
options for our systems so many of our
systems have been around for two three
decades prior to the invention of the
the iPhone or the Android and they
weren't really as mobile friendly at
that time so we're trying to modernize
those systems as we go forward with each
individual program as as applicable and
then the last one that we're really
focusing on this next biennium is
project and resource management
and that that's really establishing in
our project management structure so that
we have an intake in inventory and be
able to start aligning it to what Nathan
explained earlier the 12-month roadmap
and then on and Beyond as we get a
full-time commissioner we're hoping that
we would be able to continue that
function
and then our last goal here is reduce
reduce the cost of operating the core
Services extending the capacity of the
agency and how does Information Services
play into that it's really looking at
the technology platforms and seeing do
we have opportunities to look at the
different programs and when I say
programs in this case like software
programs and do we need to buy
individualized ones for every service
that we provide or can we leverage what
we call like economies of scale or a
single system that can provide multiple
different functions for the environment
and we we've landed on
many different areas but one of them one
of them is Salesforce which you'll hear
in many of our conversations another one
is our Enterprise business intelligence
platform which follows a very rigid
um not rigid but
well-documented data governance process
so this this goal in Dennis time in
whenever you want to is to really
improve the utilization of our patient
client system and provider systems to
really address that reporting the
payment processing the relationship
management sometimes you'll hear in I.T
we call it case management but in
healthcare case management means
something very different than in it so
we're calling it relationship management
here to distinguish it separately
um collaboration and Provider Services
through consolidation and integration so
that's going to be a lot of work I'll
just bring up a little bit later there
was a question during the program
quality and integrity regarding what are
the I.T systems that are out there and
one of them was the third priority
liability system that is on our Medicaid
enterprise system strategy of
reprocuring that system to have a
specified contract for third-party
liabilities so you'll see a lot of
synergies between Information Services
and our different divisions within this
within the department in many cases
we are working on that but it's not
something as simple as just go out and
get the vendor implement it needs to be
part of an overarching stack strategy
for our Solutions
I'll stop for a moment because I see a
question go ahead
thank you Mr chairman
um looking at the actual budget under
item 046 Consultants that was at zero
last budget and now it's in at 525 000.
can you just explain what that is is
that an attempt to bridge some Workforce
issues or something else
so the page should be on I think you're
referring to
1090 yes
and then under 046 Consultants what we
are trying to do
with additional workforces through
through the last several years but even
prior to that it's difficult to acquire
um resources in I.T specific fields and
so
in in historic historically government
has outsourced a lot of that work into
Consultants or Professional Services so
we are looking to increase our our
Consultants so that we can really staff
those teams to be effective at
delivering Medicaid enterprise system
strategies delivering our electronic
visit verification system that we're
moving forward moving forward with
better federal reporting components
supporting pqi the list goes on and on
we have well over 100 projects that we
need to Resource but we don't have well
over a hundred people that answers my
question thank you
a couple of questions since she got to
the budget page
um
I'm impressed that the general funds
really didn't change much and the
federal funds took a huge jump I just
want to make you want to speak to how
we're getting all that great I don't
want to say free money but big load of
more money
I I mean I I would likely have to go
through
um line by line to really that wasn't a
critical week to the specifics that's
fine I I mean basically we're able to
better effectively leverage federal
dollars good job
that's really what I wanted to say a
more general question I think it was
this group that recently spoke to us or
even to the larger group your new your
new Medicaid system was supposed to roll
out or is rolling out soon is that
what's the status of that
thank you for the question so we are in
the process so we've been going through
a discovery in basically requirements
Gathering phase for the last I would say
year a little over a year and really
working with different states CMS as
well as our our professional Consultants
that we hired to help us to come up with
that roadmap so we do have a roadmap and
then we're releasing two requests for
proposals in the next probably two to
three months to start that reprocurement
but it is a five-year project and so we
anticipate starting we have a roadmap
published that we can share that is
public information so maybe I'm
referring to the wrong system is there
some pretty large system that either was
posted on the last few weeks or in the
next few weeks
so thank you for that that essentially
there was two components of our
stabilization of our Medicaid management
information system
and the first one was that system was
implemented in 2005 with the hardware
and software being owned by the state
and then subsequent to that we did not
fund the life cycle replacement of that
Hardware so it was essentially 18 years
old and we the state funded a capital
investment to replace that hardware and
software to stabilize the Medicaid
management information system which we
went live two weeks ago with no no real
issues we had two bugs after we went
live that were remediated no impacts on
providers no impacts on claims
processing
there was a massive effort I was really
proud of the team for the work that they
did thank you
so sitting here it reminds me I I think
one of the things I may have been
expecting from you Mr White
um uh the commissioner had laid out for
a very nice top-down structured way of
identifying what her priorities were in
her one-year road map for Visionary
areas 12 of these 30 of these and then
by the time it got down to it she said
she had a list of like 96 or 97 uh
specific initiatives that she wanted to
pursue in the next year I think you all
were going to send me an Excel sheet of
that yes
um and the reason it's relative here
I'll take a yes on that and uh is that
what I what I'm hoping to do is to is to
get the it lay down next to those 97
initiatives just to just to be able to
crosswalk you know her priorities with
the I.T priorities
because we we still just as recently as
this last fiscal committee funded I
don't know a million dollars on an I.T
project that I didn't know where that it
project fit in the overall scheme of
priorities it was just it just felt like
here's another Target of opportunity
here's some more money let's go get it
but I didn't see where that
IT project fit Within the strategy of
the department
so um I I I've tried to ask for this a
few times I I don't know if I'm asking
for something that's just too hard to do
or not of any value but but I would like
to see the the initiatives and the I.T
next to each other
sure and and the roadmap is is nearly
finalized as the commissioner indicated
it's been actively under development so
what once that is finalized I will get
it to you
all right I I guess I guess it's not
absolutely essential for us to approve
an I.T budget but it does increase the
confidence what was 57 million dollars
that we're gonna we're gonna do here in
I.T that's that's a lot of money I just
would like to see that it's it's um it's
that that there's an articulated plan
behind it
so
do you have I interrupted you were
you're still in in mid presentation I
bet
I I can certainly address that but
representative Stringham
um maybe along those lines uh you talk
about 50 active projects and 30
additional projects under review can we
get a list of those uh and
um uh in spreadsheet form or database
form uh I have a separate question
um uh in any of the output you have
um you know whether it's from the manage
Medicaid managed care providers
or any other contracts do you get
requests and provide any access to
groups like Optum or things like that
that may may want to use that data as
part of bigger projects that they're
doing and if so is there any revenue
from that
so the first question thank you for that
question I believe we can provide the
list of the projects in an Excel format
for the second one I don't know but I
can follow up and and see if we're
sharing because with specifically to
Optum how that might happen we used to
subcontract through conduit with Optum
for our electronic data interchange
subsequent to that conduit
severed that that contract and now are
doing their own EDI transactions for the
last couple years so I don't know if we
have specific Communications with optin
but we can follow up on it
thank you
and then just for some clarity regarding
this Budget on on page 1089 and and 1090
for our office of Information Services
there's a lot of line items in there
especially for the transfers to oit that
are for ongoing operations so there's
life cycle management of our laptops
that we have here today so we have a
replacement plan for those we have a
replacement plan for the servers as well
as the networks and switches that makes
up a lot of those as well as many of the
line items from a detail perspective or
like to manage the new height system for
our integrated eligibility so when
you're looking at that transfer to oit
of
what is it 50 million 748 000 and 472
dollars the majority of that is
operations and although I could tie it
to the roadmap it's more of a
overarching support in order to be
successful with our recruitment we need
to have computers and software but it's
going to be more intangible in terms of
that kind of connection
where you'll see the tangible
connections where we can is when we have
actual projects that might be funded
from different program areas to align to
those roadmap items so as as you go
through and and you work with the
commissioner and the Nathan white you
might not be able to get exactly what
you're looking for representative
Edwards and the committee but we'll do
our best
so I just wanted to provide the clarity
this is our operations budget to keep
the lights on and there's not a lot in
here that's fluffed to support future
initiatives the future initiatives are
in I think some of our prioritized needs
that may that Nathan might be addressing
here in a moment for hb2
but
sure and and
um I I believe
um the LBA had provided you with the
trailer Bill Appropriations uh document
it was it was dated 221-23 and um there
are two two hb2 Provisions in there
um one one for 1.5 million dollars that
funds the it Consultants to manage
projects and perform the analysis and
and then and then there was a concurrent
um provision for 1.95 million and that
was to fund the I.T Consultants to
develop and Implement automated
Solutions so one is design one is
implementation I I know that you will be
seeing those once the once hb2 is
released
for historical sake was it two terms ago
or three terms ago where the I.T budget
and DHHS was really cut way way back and
it it's taken it it took us at least a
term to get you standing again where are
we at relative to to that
deforestation of the I.T plan
sorry from my perspective when I started
in May of 2018 the the budget for 1920
and 2021 was severely reduced to
basically keep the lights on and nothing
else to the point that we didn't replace
computers for a year and a half almost
two years and then
in this this biennium this current
biennium we started to recover but we
actually certainly need more funds to be
able to continue this services that we
implemented during this last biennium
especially with the pandemic that we
worked with um doit where they
implemented Microsoft teams and expanded
different services that really enable us
to do that more efficient telework as
well as on-site hybrid meetings with our
partners as well as our staff but we
also implemented Salesforce which
enabled us to bring on a better child
care licensing and registry program
Medicaid quality leverages it our public
health is leveraging it to do infectious
disease management so those tools have
increased our our actual transfers to
oit and that's where you see these bumps
from like the 45 million in 2023
adjusted authorized and the 2024
recommended where they're paying for
those license expenditures that we have
to be able to support those Solutions so
I just wanted to share that quick
thumbnail history with the newer members
of the committee that and to let you
know that in general I'm in favor and
support a robust I.T capability to
support management two terms ago
it I I wasn't part of it but it was I I
think a really a major setback to the
organization to take two years off from
I.T planning and development and
implementation and then we're still sort
of I think catching up and gaining
getting our feet under our ground and
really running that the things I'm
asking for I think will help defend your
budget this year and in coming years if
we can show a correlation between the
commissioner's requirements and
priorities and and what we're doing from
an I.T perspective to to to to make it
happen so I'm I'm trying to be helpful
in that regard but are there any other
questions here do you have more for us
Mr wieders we were getting kind of close
to the end of this right
absolutely I I was going to unless you
want to go into depth on the org chart
I'm looking to you if you want me to go
into more detail but we have 19
positions we have several vacant we are
actively recruiting them and moving that
forward I'm going to go ahead and Skip
essentially to a slide 23
and we started discussing our accounting
unit 9540 5952 which was on page 1089
starting on page 1089 of the budget book
and I would I would essentially
highlight as we already did the transfer
to Oat is where the majority of that of
the information Services budget lies and
so we we work we work with doit to
develop that line item budget and we
essentially transfer that funding over
to them but they they essentially
purchase on our behalf and Implement
with us these the different Hardware
software Solutions and Consulting
Services as well as some training for
their staff and our staff to be
effective at leveraging those new
technologies if we if we buy them or
upgrades so in many cases you upgrade
the technology it changes the the entire
look and feel we need to actually train
our staff as well so
I don't know if you want to go line by
line or if I'm seeing a nod to move on
from there
so
as we
wrap up on from Ikea accomplishments
perspective on slide 24 from a
department-wide perspective as I
referred earlier we have the sales price
Salesforce Enterprise agreement and what
that's really enabled us to do is we're
licensed in a step up perspective so we
license the whole department to be able
to use it but we're paying for it
incrementally over the next several
years and we negotiated that because we
knew we weren't going to be able to
implement solutions for everyone in the
department to use it right up front but
we knew in three years we would be able
to
but that we started with Medicaid
quality Public Health contact tracing
and investigation the child care
registry and Licensing that referred to
ombudsman's office uses it and then
we're moving it into long-term supports
and services
dcyf's capital budget is leveraging the
Salesforce environment and then we're
continuing to expand it to see how it
will apply to these different solutions
that the programs and services need as a
potential platform not a requirement but
if it fits it alleviates costs as we go
down the road
and then some of the other areas in
partnership with doit doit implemented
Microsoft teams for many functions in
our organization and it seems like a
small thing but it really empowered our
services in a totally different way it
allowed our Workforce to be able to work
with the people where they're at not
necessarily having to come have them to
come to our offices so that teleworking
is not just allowing employees to work
from home but it's also allowing them to
provide services for individuals in the
homes like for dcyf in in in where
they're at and then
as we move that forward we expanded that
into looking at other collaborative
functions like a learning management
system and that's going live this
September where we're going to have a
standardized learning management system
for professional development and some of
these will certainly directly tie into
those roadmaps that you're referring to
there's uh for some reason I'm
remembering another department bringing
in a learning management solution or is
there is there what's the strategy here
is there are we going to have one LMS
for the state employees or are we going
to have a couple lms's depending on
different departmental requirements I
think the the main reason we ended up
implementing a separate LMS than the
Statewide one was the Statewide one was
really focused on employees and ours
needed to be focused on employees plus
our Affiliates or our providers that we
work with so we need to train many
providers in our state as part of our
contracts with them they need to be
trained by us on how they perform their
services so that they can meet those
certain those requirements and the
current Statewide solution was not
available external and there was no goal
to make that an external system so so we
do have redundancy in our LMS but that
wasn't enough overt business decision
so not not yet
um we we our Statewide LMS right now is
is fairly inadequate we're actually
running a kind of a department level
open source LMS that administrative
Services runs it's their intention to to
leverage
um the the LMS that's in that's
available as as a module in our Erp
system but that's down the road some
years
so HHS had a need now and I think was
able to justify the the use of a a
another LMS at this time and and so I
think there's a rationalization exercise
that has to happen because
um
Das is going to implement a Statewide
for employees and and so where that
lands and you know two or three years
we'll we'll work on it and I'll be
monitoring both ends of that super and
and while you're uh talking about common
systems
um a key component of what the
department needs to do is to recruit and
it's been four years since you and I I
think really last got into Das and the
quality of their uh onboarding and not
onboarding but just basic recruiting
function to for a stranger from
Massachusetts or somebody to go into the
New Hampshire first site and start
looking for jobs I I think at that time
you said we were using a cheap component
that was free and that's why it was
marginal at best what are we doing in in
that area I'm not sure I said that but
this is what I remember right you know I
what can I say I simplify a lot of stuff
we'll have to review the tapes no I'm
just kidding no the uh really what we
were using was the front end to as it
existed for the infor
which is our Erp systems Personnel
module and some other website stuff and
we're that's improved a lot since then
um and then they just um actually are
are working on now I uh another leap
forward where we're gonna they're gonna
start going out to all of the um
in all of the places where folks go
normally because you don't normally
think about going necessarily to an
entity's website to find jobs you find
them in these General recruitment areas
so they're they're shifting so it's
really not a tool shift it's a strategy
shift making some investments in being
online where people are actually going
to look for jobs so I think that's
actually has a good chance of of having
a bigger impact than say spending a lot
of time and effort on our own
website per se so so that's a service
that d-o-r-t is performing for the DHS
gas is actually doing that the
department of personnel inside Das is
doing that
okay and representative Holt did you
have a question I did thank you
um looking at these department-wide
programs that are being implemented help
me to understand how
this tracks down to the individual
employee right both on training which
you were talking about but broader than
that right hours dedicated to this
project that project timesheet tracking
those broader things
thank you for the question
um it's I'm trying to make it not a
complex answer but each one of the the
way we would track it is by project so
Salesforce is just a platform but we
would have different projects for that
so like a child care registry and
Licensing project impacts that that
Bureau within economic stability that
their focus on Head Start collaboration
and child and and it also included
Melissa sincere Chief legal counsels
Division of Child Care light on Bureau
of child care licensing and then they
would dedicate time to that project to
identify the requirements do the testing
and then validate the implementation
that it that it met their needs
um as we go through like collaboration
Microsoft teams we have a small group in
DHHS of about four people that are
partnering with three or four people at
dyt to come up with the communication
and the training documents that will
then be sent out as a mass communication
to the whole department for them to
consume and then of course provide what
we call lunch and learns for training
where they could join at their
at their opportunity to learn those
systems I would say that one has a
lighter touch because and then the
learning management system really
there's not training on the learning
management system it's really
utilizing it in like from Information
Services our primary our first and
foremost training that we get out there
and track is information security and
privacy and so we we have an annual
compliance for that but our also goal is
in working and we just had to release
this today
is to have more of a light touch
throughout the year so the cyber
security group under Dennis is also
doing that and I don't know why if I
don't know if you want to touch on that
briefly but
um and and then going into that last one
the Enterprise business intelligence
that one touches every program area
because every program area has reports
and data analytics that they need to
provide but Information Services in our
our budget component of that is really
the software the services and the the
Professional Services and the the doit
component the infrastructure and we
provide it as a tool for the different
program areas to Leverage The the
software and so we'll provide the
training we'll bring We'll onboard them
but then really it comes down to them
utilizing it to develop the reports or
and and create those reports from that
system so that you can use it so it it
sort of becomes part of their day sort
of like Word and Excel does and that if
we are successful at doing it that's
what it is it's something that they just
use on an everyday basis does that
answer your question
follow-up
um kind of
I'm thinking right we're in the business
of providing services to the citizens of
New Hampshire right and at some level
there's a case right some mom in
Manchester that needs help
and how do we tie back to this effort
over here whether it's overhead in some
cases right to your your example of
using word or I'm actually working
one-on-one with the with the client
making sure that these infrastructure
and system level things we're putting in
place allow for the tracking of that so
you know that whatever this case is
right this is an effective use of time
and making sure that those hooks are
into the system-wide things systems that
we're putting in place
okay so in and correct me if I'm wrong
and how you said the statement but the
way I translate that is that's what we
do with our business analysts our
business systems analysts work with the
program areas to understand their needs
and program areas essentially our
conduit to the exists the individuals
and families where they're working with
the individuals and families and saying
this mother in Manchester needs XYZ
needs child support service payments
needs snap TANF or whatever it happens
to be how do I get this person that and
so like if it was snap intent if that
caseworker would work with that mother
and say let me help you fill out a New
Hampshire easy application
um you're going to need your social
security number and your birth date and
other financial data and I'll help you
walk you through that and there's a a
public portal so that you can either do
it on your own or if you need assistance
you can go to a district office or you
can call 1-800 ask DHHS and they can
help you through that process of
applying for SNAP and TANF and then it
goes through our system the new height
system and and develops essentially a
case where then a case manager can work
through that process with the individual
if necessary or with our internal staff
to result in that snap intent if benefit
does is that helpful or did I miss it
thank you it's helpful at a certain
level
I'm trying to figure out how to close
the loop on right there's a request from
a mom to use your example there's a
request or my example originally a mom
in Manchester who needs some Services
right we offer some services
we track that those Services were
delivered we then look back for whether
that Mom continued to need services or
this helped her out and she no longer
needs Services how do we close the loop
on there how much we invested some time
and money and right is there a way to
track any of that or is
that not capable within the current
systems
I can go back to that team and see if I
can get that answer for you but I don't
know the specifics of how that gets
closed off or can we track and if I
understand you you're trying to say if
that mother asks for these services
it goes through our system did they get
their services and did they did all of
their other services get addressed while
they go through it and can we actually
sort of monetize that is that what
you're looking for like in terms of the
I.T system supporting it as well exactly
the I.T systems that are being put in
place can they track the input request
to the output and then show that right
this F this money that was spent this
time that was invested all those that
that are the state helping out
um are helping this family or in this
case this mom and child right get to the
point where they're they're
self-sufficient or is there ongoing
needs and then we close this loop again
and that becomes the input for the next
budget cycle or the next right the
additional program they need
I can certainly follow up with a answer
to that question or if we don't have a
process for that we'll answer that way
too okay thank you so it sounds like at
least half of it is
to be done through that closed loop
referral system that you guys want out
to reacquire that it's it's the way to
go ahead and take a a client and start
to wrap around their services through a
closed-loop referral system to where we
know a referral has been made and that a
referral has been accepted but I think
the back half of that is sort of
something I've never asked you all about
and that's what representative hole is
asking that's interesting to me is that
do we have a way to go and just track
the completion of those services or the
quality of those services
but that's what you just said you're
going to go look at
go ahead represent let me give an
example right to the to as you were
talking about whether the mom in in
Manchester needs help filling out the
forms and applying for this there's
there's an employee who helps walk them
through that that that's great
um
they spend an hour with that and
will they need help next time I'm
thinking just how to close the loop
because as a systems engineer I think
about we have some request I want to go
all the way back around and make sure
that the initial initial request was met
that the needs were were addressed
understand if we invested time how do we
make this easier next time so that we
learn from oh we're seeing a high
percentage of people who need help
walking through the forums maybe it's
just the forms aren't intuitive enough
and a small tweak to the forms would
make this such that we don't need to
spend an hour on the phone right this is
tracking inputs and outputs at a system
level for the services provided what to
to answer that question directly we do
have a process on all of our systems
that basically and our caseworkers where
they if they get a question and they're
following up they they go through and
when they close out the case or if they
say they're done
they basically have provided the
services and we have a record of that
um so I I but it's every system is that
way so we haven't like we don't have a
way in which to say
for David Wieters that might be getting
snapped out of child support payments as
well as in a mental health system as
well as maybe having a a father that
he's providing advocacy for on the
elderly adult care system we don't have
it crosswalked across all of those
partially because of privacy concerns
and partially because it's that's a
complex component of building it
together so it's it's sort of nuanced
but we certainly have and you'll
probably that question might be that
specific question might be really well
posed towards one of the program areas
like that you'll see next week and and
other and as you go through the rest of
the programs you'll find that it'll be I
would go back to the other division
directors to answer those questions on
how they close the loop on the services
that they're providing
yeah follow-up so this is effectively
looking for
what I would deem low-hanging fruit in
terms of program Effectiveness things
that are easy to make small changes to
go back to the forms write the snap
forms and whatever else if someone if
you find that there's a lot of time
invested to help people walk through the
forms a small change to the layout of
the screens online is a is a highly
leveraged investment that makes it
easier for everybody is and is effective
and I'm looking if there's any metrics
in place or any data in place that we
can sort through to find those things
just to better use the resources we have
in in this the short answer is and I'll
use the the new heights example they do
monthly releases and it's both for bug
fixes as well as enhancements and so
every time a caseworker or an individual
says hey it would be nice if this form
that you have that requires me to put in
my birthday 27 times before I get to
click submit if you could can I just put
it in once I'm not saying that's
inaccurate but that I was just using it
as an example can you just have can I
just put it in once and you just
remember it all the way through so that
you click submit and I only have to
remember to put my birthday in once we
do have a process for pulling that in
and saying okay this is an enhancement
that's impacting a lot of individuals we
should update this system and we put it
into the release planning
so time check uh it's like 246 I want to
get us out of here at three so we're now
in the speed rounds uh so fast answers
short uh I I know you still have
material you want to go over but I'm
gonna I'm already jumping to page 26 in
your second area about the Enterprise
business intelligence platform and I'm
gonna ask you some interrelated stuff to
what we're doing to support the
prescription drug affordability board to
make sure that when they go and do data
queries to bring sensitive business
information in that
it's going into our systems in a way in
which we've got a common platform that
we can begin to do the data analysis and
data queries from are we are we are we
developing that plan around the
prescription drug affordability boards
data requests that are coming or are
they yet to be integrated into your
plans for the business intelligence
system
do you have the answer
the the prescription drug affordability
board
um still hasn't collected any Revenue
they don't have an executive director
um so I I mean at this point in time we
we're just in the process of finalizing
the mou
um so so that you know that that aspect
is considered there but we've received
no specific requests around data or what
that data would even look like okay
that's that's what I thought
um I just wanted to verify that
um and and then since you're working on
the mou maybe you can anticipate this if
if they want to do something with their
I.T that isn't consistent with the
Department's I.T infrastructure and
strategic Direction can they still do it
because I know the commissioner has very
little authority that that with with
that board so I'm just curious if we're
potentially setting up to have redundant
I.T systems and data collection efforts
sure and I I
um does Mr weeders have the authority to
say yes or no to an I.T request by the
board or Willie
well all of the all of the contracts
come through me so I have regular
interactions with agencies about if
things seem to be going off the rails
from a standards perspective and I feel
like you know we could guide that and it
and honestly it would make no sense to
do what you're suggesting because what I
was going to comment that we have a
pretty much a world-class ebi
environment now it would and it can
ingest any data we want to give it and
and manipulate the data appropriately as
needed so I think we have what's needed
already so so to build something out
from scratch wouldn't make any sense
unless and I'll qualify this depending
on how it's administratively attached
and what qualifications exist under that
there may be a reason not to
so so for example if you're if you're
saying okay I've created this
administrative administratively attached
entity I'm not using DHHS specifically
that has a oversight function for
example then you know we might prescribe
certain types of of data integration and
data sharing and then there might be a
reason to do something else
I know I'm being non-specific but very
intentionally no I I I get it I'm just
uh just checking how how big this is at
this point and uh just as an FYI I I
they don't have an i this board won't
have an oversight function within
government it will have a regulatory
view of the pharmaceutical industry so
representative Walnut did you have a
comment
no I have a couple questions I want to
ask before we finish up I think we're
getting close
well we sort of skipped over I think we
skipped over page 25.
which was your challenges and I the
first one I see there is the low wages
and how it's impacting
um your work and I would like to know if
um
I know we're going to have a 10 wage
increase and I guess I wonder in your
area where people are
highly trained and
technical skills is this going to help
us
enough this is enough to attract people
to those jobs and then I have another
question I'd like to follow up with
so I would thank you for the question
um I would say that certainly a 10
increase will help but we're also
working through that 12-month roadmap a
component of that is Recruitment and
Retention goals and so we're going to be
looking at how we can leverage funding
to advance our Recruitment and and
retention components including
recognition of Staff
highlighting functions like economic
like the tourism in our state like the
tourist functions and whatnot as well as
trying to figure out what is it that
really brings people to a to a job but
the component that we're really trying
to address here in the Staffing is that
we put in a request as Nathan indicated
earlier
for additional Professional Services or
Consultants to off offset that impact
and even if we were able to retain the
existing staff we are we are over
described in projects and and solutions
that we need to address for either
legislative mandate or just to manage
services for our citizens that we need
those Professional Services teams to
come on board and in many cases the
reason why we think that's a good use of
our funds in the state is that those can
be you can bring them on for
purpose-built Solutions
and build those Solutions out and then
you can let those Consultants those high
paid Consultants go and then really
leverage your existing Baseline staff to
maintain and move that those Solutions
forward
I don't know if Dennis if you had
anything else yeah I would have a
similar answer 10 10 absolutely helps
particularly as you work your way up
this you know 10 of a bigger numbers a
bigger number so that it helps there
um you know it wouldn't create parity
between the private sector and the state
but I don't think that's the intent and
I don't think we've ever had parity
actually I think we may be in a more
severe situation than we've been in some
other times but I I don't think that
seeking parity is going to be our
solution so I I do other things
motivating things as well similar to
David with um you know trying to create
situations that make you want to work in
the state make it a really good place to
be
understanding that the compensation may
not be uh you know directly competitive
with um you know your private sector
counterparts
my other question was where would I find
I know you're going to try to contract
some of this work out
where do I find that in the budget the
contracts
that you're hoping to so so if um I I
believe the LBA had sent you the
governor's recommended Budget Trailer
Bill appropriation I believe that's
posted online right now and and within
that there's there's two hb2 Provisions
that are funded out of the 23 Surplus
um for it automated Solutions analysis
it automated Solutions implementation
ones for 1.5 million dollars to General
funds and one is one for 1.95 million
and I can certainly send the link that
I'm looking at okay
um and the other question I have about
that is did you have any other
prioritized needs that did not get
included in your budget or in-house Bill
too
um
a majority of our prioritized needs in
the it realm were funded there are some
smaller
prioritized needs that were not funded
that Dave and I had discussed trying to
find a way maybe by putting off some
projects for a period of time I can
certainly bring those forward
um those that were not funded to this
committee thank you
so a follow-up on that is on these
prioritized needs are you able to show
where your I.T prioritized needs map
into the Commissioners roadmap of 97
items
because that to me that's a strong way
to justify a prioritized need is it's
the commissioner's priorities
um certainly and the Professional
Services specifically but the other
items could map to those but they're
going to map to all of her roadmaps
because they all are reliant on those
infrastructure services that we're
trying to provide so those Professional
Services groups they'll be assigned to
different work streams to deliver the
the tasks that she has for those
roadmaps I wouldn't say maybe not all of
them but I would say the majority of her
roadmap items will have some sort of tie
to those Consulting dollars that we're
moving forward
okay well thank you
um I I think we're going to be
continually in touch on this
um so uh so thank you for coming in
today uh
the so the part of this is over I I just
want to say I I think I think we're
working pretty well in terms of once
once each of you get going and you start
asking questions it's still in my intent
to not be interrupting you to let you go
ahead and have sort of your natural flow
and I know that that's unusual for most
chairmen but but I'm okay being unusual
so I just think it's a more effective
conversation that way
um and is there anything for the good of
the cause here before we break up anyone
in the audience feel Miss Santa Nella
you've been here all afternoon can we do
anything for you
okay anyone else in the audience that
has anything to add or say or contribute
questions from the committee uh not
seeing Mr Ripple last call yeah could I
just add that if anybody wants to take a
tour of the sununu center on
next Friday morning please let me know
so I put out an email last night and I
got three responses uh one of whom was
from a member one of which is from a
member of division one who may not have
realized that they have a full morning
of bills that day so
um I I'm sort of reluctant to ask the
department to give two tours for two
people
um so if anybody else wants to attend
please let me know so I was one of them
and I'll I'll go wherever the center of
mass is so uh go ahead I was just gonna
say I was interested but when we were
told that we would have that day as
though our one day off I've booked a
commitment with my kids so I apologize
that I won't be able to attend
maybe we could uh walk through there
with a video to give you a feel we could
get one of those yeah so so
representative Paul you've you signed up
for two or three tours or
uh no I actually contacted and had one
this morning
oh yes so tell us what what are your
impressions in 20 seconds or less what
are your impressions so I told the
director Jerry that the condition of the
rooms and the hallways was better than
my college dorm
not that I want to go right it was in
better shape than what I went to college
for or the places I slept in college but
that says more probably about my college
than it does about the sununa center I I
had made that same observation and I
extended it to the my military facility
so it is better than that
um so if if representative hole is gone
is there anyone else who who's who's the
other there was one member from division
two I think it might have been
representative Murray
I'm not I'm not positive okay okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna stay out of that but
I'll I'll jump on in whichever one you'd
end up with
representative will you have another
um the one observation that was made is
that space is really big for the number
of people that are there I mean right
you could easily feel very isolated
given
it's yes they can close off wings but
the hallways are whatever 10 feet wide
so
okay so uh I think at this point we're
ready to adjourn
um all right division three is now
adjourned
thank you